Hassan Kadam has to examine the map
carefully in order to find his little
home village of Gurkha knock in
southeastern Turkey yes it's been nearly
50 years since he and his wife Jeanette
left there and came to Berlin as guest
workers originally they wanted to return
home after a couple of years that was
imported Iike the politicians weren't
concerned about us no one talked about
the need to integrate people because
they've been here for so long we only
heard about integration for the first
time ten years ago or maybe 15 and then
they asked why haven't people integrated
the Katims found their way even without
government support the key for them was
learning the German language Jeanette
Cottam learned German after work with
the help of a radio program but she also
thinks it's absurd when some people
compared the guest workers of that era
to the war refugees of today won't be
able were happy to earn a bit of money
we could care for our children and have
a better way of life it had just
continued that way if not then we could
have just gone back home but not the
refugees
nearly 1 million Turkish guest workers
arrived in Germany in the 1960s and 70s
many of them were later joined by their
families and stayed even though at first
there were few opportunities and one
opportunity next to paid work is
education according to ser hot kyuh kyuh
Ali he's researching the topic of
immigration his father also came to
Germany as a guest worker and his mother
was a teacher
they encouraged their son as well as the
Turkish women they knew it was often
women who were illiterate themselves she
started holding the first sewing courses
with them what is the next step she
taught them to read and write that was
the way to make it clear to them that
education is important that's belong it
is all of genetic atoms five children
went to university she hopes that
today's refugees have it easier than the
guest workers did back then politically
she stood on koma politicians really
have to take care of them
but the refugees themselves also really
have to try don't try then no one can
force them to integrate think it has to
be both sides side is a table so they
they say it's taken them nearly two
decades to really feel at home in
Germany it could have gone more quickly
with a little bit of help